[Applause]
[Music]
it was done when the benediction had a
son file a gentleman was from my role
denied by surprise I kept in to see your
opening and I know you are alive I know
that smile and nothing
[Music]
there is way to sleep it's the young
[Music]
there is laughter
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the war
[Music]
nobody ever even asked for up above
nothing matters but the ones you love
so get out with me now you've gotta know
just over
[Music]
[Music]
there is
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thanks I love a depressing
song you know I've been writing them for
15 years now and to be honest over that
time I've come to kind of believe that
they're not really depressing at all in
fact I think they're kind of the most
important songs we have songs that sing
of sorrow of grief of longing of the
darker side of love the underside of
being alive
these are the songs I just never tire of
hearing and I never tire of writing
because they make me feel less alone
they speak to a very real part of being
human that can often be hidden in fear
and shame and push deep down where it
lingers and rots but I think in
listening to these songs to really
listening can allow us to refill these
hard emotions but in a cathartic and
healing way in a way that reminds us as
we listen that we're not alone in
darkness there's a Japanese phrase known
as mono no aware which very roughly
translates as the bittersweet poignancy
of things or the pathos or arnis of
things it's a valuable awareness of
impermanence both a kind of gentle
transient sadness as things passed by in
life but also a deeper softly lingering
sadness about the impermanence of all
reality mono no aware can be manifesting
lots of life stories and moments and
songs and one example in Japanese
culture is the celebration of the cherry
blossom the cherry blossom in and of
itself is no more impressive than that
of an apple or orange tree but what sets
it apart is its brevity cherry blossoms
fall within a single week
can be whisked away in my gentlest
breeze and it's this that makes it more
beautiful it's utterly fragile and
fragility gives life is poignancy now
being a cheery chap nothing speaks to me
more than this and you know I think it's
been the essence of my songwriting for
years of what moves me to write or
inspires me to sing because pain and
grief and doubt when it's made manifest
in music and song when it's made
beautiful in poetry and painting can
build a community in the kinship in the
knowledge that we are none of us alone
in darkness my next song is one that I
call killing me and as the name suggests
it's not a dancefloor favorite but it
isn't miserable it's full of love and
hope and I think it exemplifies
everything I've been talking about and
it's the first song I've written from
the perspective of somebody else
specifically my grandmother as she lives
on without my late grandfather as she
experiences new things in her life her
grandchildren getting married having
their own children speaking at Ted all
the while she lives without norther
while she misses her soulmate thank you
[Music]
sweetheart would you wake up today I
promise you but recognize my face I
wanna show you how I've grown in this
place this place I'm not alone and I
know I'll be okay but it's always hard
when the winter comes to stay the world
[Music]
it's killing me that you're not tease me
I'm living heaven but I'm feeling guilty
and you won't believe the world I can
see this world is changing me but I
would love you faith
Oh everything is taller these days only
I feel smaller and time washes away so
much I could show how all the
great-grandchildren have been loving
like we did when we were
I've been loved in life
when we were
to me
but I'm feeling
[Music]
this world is changing me
[Music]
[Music]
that sure
me
but
[Music]
this world is changing me
[Music]
energy
[Music]
but I'm feeling
see oh you won't believe the wonders
I've seen
[Music]
this world is changing me that I will
love you faithfully
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]